i'm kevin durant i'm stephen curry and  this is the ultimate game of pit  only with police report i'll go first  start in  damn i actually might get a letter off  there  mid-range old school  corner jimmy  hold on to that one  sorry glass work  holy [ __ ]  best out of five right  uh oh that's what you used to do in the  freezer  oh that's funny huh let's pick with your  fanny over there  oh come on  logo jay  man what a spirited game  come on q  [Music]  he's feeling good  [Music]  we're gonna shoot eight  eight hundred footers right you gotta  keep it simple  [Music]  [Music]  stay alive oh my god  am i now the greatest shooter in the  world  finally i want something  that's a dope trophy  it's a fisher right now put my beer in  here  thank you appreciate it  that's the expensive stuff and carry  i don't know what it says but  i don't know what's supposed